IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
SO IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION, THE HASHTAG GAME IS
VERY SIMPLE: WE COMBINE TWO
UNRELATED THINGS INTO SOME PUN
FORM.
YOU MIGHT SAY WE'RE PUNNING ON
EMPTY.
SEE, THAT'S HOW THAT WORKS.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS LITERALLY
#AddAPunRuinAPun.
SO EXAMPLES WILL BE, PUN DMC.
OR PUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
AND PUN-SIZED SNICKERS!
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ONT HE
CLOCK STARTING NOW AND GO.
YES, PAUL SCHEER.
>> PUNGER GAMES STARRING
PUNNIFER LAWRENCE AS KATPUTNISS
EVERPUN.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS A LITTLE PUN-CLUNKY,
BUT I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS.
BRETT GELMAN.
>> STEVEN SIEGAL'S PUNDER SIEGE
TWO.
>> CHRIS: PUNTS!
PAUL SCHEER.
>> PUNISHER, THE MOVIE STARRING
DOLPH PUNGREN.
>> CHRIS: PUNTS!
PAUL DALY.
>> PUN IN THE SUN. FUN IN THE
SUN.
>> CHRIS: PUNTS. ANDY DALY.
>> 2,000 POUNDS EQUALS ONE
METRIC PUN.
>> CHRIS: OHH. PUNTS.
BRETT GELMAN.
>> PUNBREAKABLE STARRING SPAMUEL
L. CRAPSON.
>> CHRIS: OKAY POINTS. THANK
YOU FOR ALTERING THE OTHER ONES.
PAUL.
>> PUNGELINA JOLIE'S PUNBROKEN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. PUNDERWFUL.